e
histoire à sa manière, et le
résultat est spectaculaire,
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le "West Side Story" version
e LE film du temps des Fêtes,
car les critiques
ithyrambiques.
- Bien oui, c'est un bon film.
C'est un grand film!
j'ai tj'ai tj'ai tj'ai tj'ai tj.
♪ ♪ ♪
- "West Side Story" a d'abord
été une comédie musicale
en 1957 avant de devenir,rempor.
♪ ♪ ♪ Ce drame inspiré du "Romét
Juliette" de William Shakespeare
met en scène deux amoureux
aux prises avec é
de deux clans. L'un est issu
de la classe ouvrière blanche
et l'autre d'émigrés
portoricains. Le nouveau film
de Steven Spielberg est très
différ
nous dit François Lévesque
FRANÇOIS LÉVESQUE,
critique de cinéma
droit à des acteurs blancsavec ,
très foncé, ce qui était
courante à Hollywood à l'époque.
Spielberg a décidé de recourir
à des acteurs dont l'héritage
ce qui est une excellente chose.
♪ ♪ ♪
un sourire... Pow!
- Le racisme estde la version d,
qui s'est approre,
selon Michel Coulombe.
MICHEL COULOMBE,
- Le principe même de Spielberg,
comme ça qu'il travaille,
c'est de pousser les curseurs,
toujours, d'y aller à fique,
on veut en tirer le maximum,avee
puisque que Rita Moreno,
qui était la Anita de 1961ionion
dans ce film-ci.
(en espagnol)
- Des critiques s'attendent
à ce que "West Side Story"
aux Oscars en partie à cause
de seses,
mais surtout à cause de sa
condamnation du cercle vicieux
- Je pense que c'est un message
qu'on 'entendre
aujourd'hui, au vu de tout ce
qui se passe dans l'actualité.
prenant et qui prouve
que Stberg
a eu beaucoup d'instinct!
Troisième Guerre mondiale?
- Le film "West "
prendra l'affiche dès ce jeudi.
Ici Lontréal.ontréal.ontréal.o.